(imitates cork popping)
- (laughing) That it?
That's it?
I'm supposed to feel
rich when I open this.
(thumping music)
- It's pretty, I'll give it that.
That's a beautiful liquid.
- I don't drink very often,
but when I do, champagne's where it's at.
- I think champagne's made by fairies.
- I haven't had champagne in hours.
(lofty music)
- I feel like a good champagne
should be really light and crisp
and should be just,
this one's a little too, like
pee yellowy for me.
- It's got a little stank on it.
- More stank, the more expensive it is?
- I don't know.
I don't know!
- We're writing down
how much we think it is.
- $15.43?
- Does anything cost that?
- I think I might've overshot.
- I guessed $80.00
- Oh.
(cork popping)
- No.
No!
(champagne pouring)
- Everyone drink.
- All right.
Wow!
- That's delightful, yeah.
- This is like what you bring out
to your ladies night book club.
- It's definitely fruitier
than the other one.
- What kind of fruit?
- All of them.
- $35.00 a bottle.
- There's a lot of bubbles, and thus
I think it's about a
medium priced champagne.
- I'm gonna say $17.99.
(cork popping)
(everyone exclaiming)
- He got it exactly right?
- Yeah.
- On Price is Right you get like, $500.00.
(champagne pouring)
- You know when you eat live octopus?
- No?
- When you eat live octopus it like,
bites at you, you know?
Because you're just both like
clawing in nature,
just like eating each other.
- This is Mimosa champagne.
That's what this is.
This is what you pour into orange juice.
- If this is expensive, I'm leaving.
- I'm a simple boy.
If I like something, it's probably cheap,
and if I hate something
it's probable expensive.
It's gotta be over 9000 dollars.
(everyone laughing)
(cork popping)
- I've always pronounced it "cook's"
- This has failed me in every way.
- This is the size of my face.
(champagne pouring)
- Cheers! Last one, y'all.
- That one's when we're like,
it goes in your mouth
and your cheeks go...
- It would actually be good
with apple juice in it.
- Oh, that's dangerous man.
One you add juice, you're gonna
down that like a mother--
- You're damn right I will.
(everyone laughing)
- It's not very good!
It's not very good!
- I'm gonna win this round.
- I'm saying this is a $75.00
bottle of champagne.
- I'm gonna go with $29.99.
I think this is like, in
the middle of the road.
- $8.59?
I felt like it was a
pretty weak champagne.
(cork popping)
- I'll take that win.
- What? You were over!
- Today we tasted a couple
different kinds of champagne.
I still think champagne
is made by fairies.
- I feel wonderful.
- We did what my good
friend 50 Cent would call
a champagne campaign.